pour montrer en fait que vous avez bon
fond carisse envers une interview
bisounours
à
la dernière fois où vous avez pleuré
je crois un premier fonctionner comme
quoi hein quoi je pleurais à
laquelle j'avais offert votre corps à
une jeune fille carys ses
personnages
c'était très tôt très tôt non 13 ans
j'étais déjà musclé comme ça
j'ai libéré sébastien à vous devriez ça
vous plairait il est beau le chien pour
vous c'est quoi la soirée idéale à 2
à 2 à 2 dans une voiture avec un gros
joint oui
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez faite dans votre vie
je vous sors des fleurs à ma mère a très
bien
il aime sa mère
vraiment vous entendez mieux avec les
gens de quel signe
astrologique
je crois pas ça
y a rien à faire vous aimez les petits
chatons sur internet sur internet nombre
et aimait bien les petits chats félicien
francis cabrel et graphistes ou
alors
vous l'appellerait comment votre premier
bébé
se demandent peut-être dans les bras de
qui vous sentez vous le mieux
le bras pour fait à
pudique vous avez quelque chose à dire à
votre maman là
je veux en avoir en prêt à vous allez
souvent vous assurerez chose tous les
jours super important afin qu il y en a
que
19 et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
in a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux